- I don't like anyone listening
to the songs that I write.
- Ever?
- They're for me.
- "Little Voice" was the idea of wanting
to return to this phase in my life
when I was
in my early 20's,
I had to embody this idea of
trusting my own voice.
- I just don't have that thing.
- What you're feeling now, use it.
Gonna make a great song.
- ♪ Tell her... ♪
- I think what's interesting about
Sara's work is they were really inspired
by very small, personal things
that were happening in her life,
and that really interested me
on a writing level.
- To have a show where
music is at the core of it
was a wonderful thing because
the music was informing the story
as much as the story was
informing the music.
- You're a great songwriter.
Tell them what inspired that.
- I really loved getting to know Brittany
through the music of the show.
- I grew up playing piano,
so I had the basic skills,
but Sara gave great advice when
it comes to singing.
She taught me how to play guitar.
I started playing things
I never thought I could play.
When we started singing together,
I think that's when we realized
we have a lot of
musical chemistry.
- She came with
such a spirit of collaboration.
That's such an element of who Bess is.
- As my Dad always said, sometimes
you just got to do it for the love of it.
- Sara talked about New York as being
the kind of heartbeat of the show.
It's a place that's just
full with opportunity.
You're hearing songs everywhere.
- From the subway buskers
to people in the park,
the sounds and the rhythms of
the city are so alive and vital.
It certainly was a huge part of
my musical journey.
- Give you some swagger.
- ♪ I've spent too much time ♪
♪ Wasted at the borderline ♪